[Music]
so time for the press preview then
checking out monday's front pages for
you
and tonight we'll see what is making the
headlines with the journalist and author
yasmin alabai brown and the political
editor at the scottish sun rachel watson
that great to see this sunday evening
we'll chat in a moment uh we'll check
out those front pages for you first
though let's start with the metro it's
leading on president silence defiant
victory day message in which he likened
president putin to hitler
well similar comments are on the front
of the telegraph but this time from the
defense secretary ben wallace who is set
to accuse mr putin of mirroring the
fascism and tyranny of 70 years ago
fresh u.s sanctions on the bosses of
russia's gazprom bank is on the front of
the ft
meanwhile the guardian goes on the cost
of living crisis reporting a survey has
found more than two million britons have
missed meals in the last month
as they can't afford it
many families are facing another energy
price shock because prices doubled for
one in four households that's uh on the
front of the mirror
in a bid to help boost the economy boris
johnson is set to remove hundreds of eu
laws according to the times
meanwhile the mail claims are rattled
sakir stama has pulled out of a major
speech as he faces pressure over a
police investigation into alleged
lockdown breaking
the sun page tribute to minder and
sweeney tough guy dennis waterman who
sadly died at the age of 74.
and let's finish on some good news the
star says it's time to slap on the sun
cream as britain faces its hottest
summer
ever
don't forget by scanning the qr code
that you can see on screen join the
program you can check out those front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch and listen to us and as i say i'm
joined tonight by yasmin alibi brown and
rachel watson so
let's get cracking uh we'll start with
ukraine i think um and rachel the front
of the metro victory will be ours again
tomorrow victory day in russia and we're
all waiting to see what president putin
has to say because in many ways he's uh
between a rock and a hard place isn't he
as to whether he claims victory or says
it's full on war
yeah and as you say there's been a lot
of waiting anticipating just what will
happen tomorrow and what vladimir putin
will say and i think today specifically
but over the weekend we've seen those
western countries um allies ukraine nato
members try to get ahead of that so
we've seen additional visits to ukraine
for example over the last and 24 hours
and there's stories on
most of the front pages around
additional sanctions for example and
this front page in the metro which
focuses on that video and that president
zelinski put out
um today
on you know what he sees um as um
coming down the road for ukraine and i
think this is something that president
zelenki has been very um good at
throughout the
conflict in the country i think he's a
very good communicator and he's made a
number of these videos to try and get in
front of it and this is a war like
we've spoken about before like no other
it's been fought um obviously in ukraine
but there is this whole communication
site as well that president zelinski has
really harnessed and i think i watched
that video of him earlier and it's very
emotional it's very touching it's very
you know the fact that he um is so
defiant still and i think that is you
know we've all kind of grown to know so
much about this man that people knew
very little of before and i think it is
because he is so good at getting that
message across and you know as i said i
think there has been this huge effort to
try and get in front of vladimir putin
and what he might say there's an
expectation that he might refer to this
as a war for the first time we know in
russia he's spoken about it as a special
operation previously and that is
something that
experts have said over the last few days
they expect him to start referring to as
an as a war and to really ramp up um the
fact that he will continue to fight it
yeah um it was a very powerful uh uh
message wasn't it he really has uh
mastered the communications during this
conflict um
in front of the daily telegraph putin is
mirroring nazis says the defense
secretary he's going to make this speech
as well tomorrow and of course victory
day is meant to be uh about the soviets
um celebrating victory over the nazis
but
putin has claimed all along that this
conflict is about getting rid of the
nazis from from ukraine which is which
is ridiculous
it is ridiculous to us
but
you know countless russians and their
state-controlled
media
absolutely believe that
and it's also it's so easy to to produce
images
and conversations as we know um to
persuade a population which has no
very little access to alternative
realities if you like
but it's very important and interesting
to look at this nazi comparison because
one of the things the west
should have acknowledged a long time ago
is that russia
was with the allies
when the nazis were defeated and
real sacrifices were made by russians
then
and to see that country
under putin today
how history has completely turned around
but i i always get very uneasy when the
word nazi is used
kind of carelessly this is this is a
particularly
vicious
war by a man who will not be stopped in
and he just wants that
old soviet empire back
yeah and he's not going to stop yeah he
does have a a a very warp sense of of
history doesn't he um uh ft rachel
talking about uh fresh sanctions the
sanctions keep on coming are are they
making uh a big enough impact do you
think that
yazmin talking about the propaganda
working in russia um the people are
suffering there economically
yeah and i think that is one of the
areas that if you read the story in the
ft so they talk about they open the
story talking about the us
i'm targeting 27 financial executives in
russia with fresh sanctions and but we
go further into the story and we look at
other countries for example they talk
about
the g7 group and how they will look to
try and and put more financial pressure
on russia and those and that it deems to
be um involved with putin's regime or
close to him so really really hardening
the stance on sanctions which they've
continued to try and do we've seen this
done in groups and almost blocks extra
people and sanctions on extra people for
example hardening those sanctions on
people that they're already on and then
we hear that the eu again are going to
look again at the sanctions that they
have imposed because they obviously do
them as a block so i think the fact that
they will negotiate for their sanctions
and it is that lever that they hope will
just continue to push pressure
on the people in russia and you see it
you know it's not just sanctions like
this but some businesses that pulled out
of the country so
you know it feels like a very long time
ago when
it was on the news and we heard of all
these companies and shops and
restaurants that were shutting in russia
and they were going to close down their
business there i'm streaming websites
for example and it's all about creating
that pressure but the question is do
the people of russia and do they see
that as the west being too strict do
they believe the propaganda and that
i'm putting puts on them and we know
that not all russians do we know we've
seen the process on the street i was
watching sky's coverage earlier speaking
to people in russia who don't want this
war they they're already referring to it
as a war they don't want it they they
can't believe what's happening and i
think that's what people hope that these
sanctions will do and continuing to
harden the stance on that
is one way of trying to force this war
backwards yeah um uh all very good
points um let's move on from ukraine uh
to what yazmin
we haven't spoken about brexit for a
while haven't have we and it's back in
the news um uh uh following uh the
announcement last night that shinfane is
now the largest party in the uh north
island assembly let's look at this story
in the metro brexit round back on as
shin fein calls for a united island and
dominick robb doing the rounds this
morning
threatening to uh to rip up the brexit
deal
warning that it could put stability in
northern ireland in
peril what's going to happen here do you
think it's the queen's speech of course
coming up
i cannot believe that we've got a
government in this country which is
prepared to rip up its own agreement
its own
long fought agreement which kind of saw
off one prime minister
now they're threatening to rip it up
what did it ever mean to them i mean the
situation in northern ireland is very
delicate
it's an important historical moment but
there seems to be as we you know if you
read the front page of the
ft financial times a kind of denial
of what has just happened
um nobody expected sinn fein to to do as
well as they did and they're
underplaying it and sometimes kind of
rewriting history almost um you know
we've got
shin fein haven't gained street
um brandon lewis northern ireland um
secretary says or will say tomorrow
um
i'm sorry this is real it happened
what has been amazing about the good
friday agreement
is the fact that they all do have to
work together i wish we had that system
incidentally that after election you
just do have to get on
if they're going to
put that at risk and rip up their own
agreement
lord knows what happens to brexit next
but of course the dep refusing to uh to
form a new assembly until it until
changes are made rachel so it is a bit
of a stalemate
yeah it isn't it feels you know yes and
says they do have to work together they
do for this to move forward but we find
ourselves in a bit of a paralysis with
this if the dep won't agree to work with
shin pain as things stand
nobody can move forward at the moment
and i think that is a huge issue here
we're obviously talking about the
northern ireland protocol and brexit but
there's also um the talk around a
potential border pole and deep um shin
fin leaders talking about a border pole
could happen within the next five years
um so there's that side of it
as well that i think is really important
and
you know the comments from brandon lewis
he's absolutely trying to play down the
fact
and that shin fame being the largest
party could lead to this um his comments
massively trying to underplay what's
happening but i think when you look back
at polls as well
it was really interesting i went back
and looked at some polls in northern
ireland and the republic of ireland over
the past
um a couple of months
showed that in northern ireland there's
a majority i think it was 54 in the poll
that i saw i carried out recently that
northern ireland staying in the uk and
but when you look at the republic of
ireland a majority supported
um a united ireland
but
there was less support when people felt
that it would impact their taxes or
spending or at the impact that that
could have on
um flag or national anthem for example
so there's so much of this it's such a
huge story and it's just come you know
it's really growing over the weekend and
as yesterday said nobody expected
champagne to do as well so we are now
having discussions on a lot of things
that people maybe didn't think would be
having at this point in time yeah and uh
as you say uh that's it so yeah so let's
come in yes
i just want to celebrate
michelle o'neill the the female leader
i mean it is quite a moment to have her
as a leader whatever one thinks of the
political parties and she's has a real
gift for communication so
you know as a woman i
honor her
really okay well let's talk about a a
different leader kierstarma
who
with a hangover from beergate continues
doesn't it um daily mail yasmine um well
it's been on their front front page for
the last few days now rattlestammer
snubs the chance to clear the air um
there was this leaked memo yesterday
what would you make of this story hasn't
well it's not going to go away now until
the police investigation concludes
and um
you know we find out whether the rules
were broken
and if rules were broken that both he
and angela rainer will have to decide
what to do but what a and and you know i
think that's right and fair but what
isn't fair
is if this is used to create an
impression
you know which is that all politicians
are as bad as one another because what
happened in downing street is quite
another matter i do hope the su grey
report is soon published
i'm not going to defend kyostama until i
know what really happened what the
police say
but you can't
make an equivalence between
you know
parties which had karaoke and suitcases
of drink being brought in and what we
really need is for all these reports now
to be done and for us to find out what
the
an independent investigation is telling
us
uh rachel um a quick thought on this i
mean i guess the problem is that um
uh as always if you're up front at the
beginning about exactly what went on
then things get a lot easier later
further down the line
yeah and it's a problem that all
political parties seem to have if you
look back over the last few months when
you just hold your hands up and say this
is what happened i'm sorry and provide
the details when you're asked about it
things people move on pretty quickly but
we start with the uk government with
owen patterson with um partygate now we
see it with the labour party but that
refusal just to put your hands up and
provide the details that you've been
asking for just prolongs it it makes it
even worse and i think you know i've not
had um been able to look inside the mail
at this story but the fact that starmer
appears to have canceled a speech and an
event that he could take journalists
questions
and at tomorrow it just is another bad
look isn't it and i think that is you
know it's all about the perception here
as well
okay and uh just 20 seconds jasmine
front page of the guardian the new
doctor who has been uh uh announced
formally he was at the baftas shooti
gagwa um uh are you pleased about this
very very very pleased a scots
from rwanda
gay
wonderful
what's not to like and what about rachel
the fact that he forgot to wear a shirt
at the baftas
you get creative with these don't you
they all get very creative he needs to
get in his time machine and go back and
fix that i think thank you both very
much we'll speak again in half of that